we're kicking off another massive
weekend here in las vegas events like
life is beautiful already underway
several sports events like boxing and
the raiders taking over this weekend and
it looks like that uptick in tourism is
making everything a lot more expensive
too sasha loftus joining us live now
here in the studio to explain
denise we're used to busy weekends here
in las vegas but that what's different
this time is the skyrocketing room rates
many say they had to come up with a plan
b to afford a trip here
it's easy to see our city is packed and
as popular as ever
as thousands head here this weekend for
a myriad of events like life is
beautiful
[Music]
it's really really expensive but it
turns out prices are also out of this
world as many tourists complain about
hotel rates that are hard to swallow the
prices went up crazy vegas.com showed
some shocking prices friday from
331 dollars a night at circus circus to
places like the win and encore just over
a thousand they raised when demand is
high they lower their rates when supply
is high jonathan fine of fine
entertainment management says while
these numbers aren't ideal he calls them
a sign of a booming economy that's
officially bounced back from the start
of the pandemic you listen to everyone
say the economy is in shambles but room
rates are crazy because demand is is
high still many say it's truly breaking
the bank with a lack of options or even
deals to cut costs they used to offer a
lot of offers in las vegas especially
like if you go to casino and the hotel
is really really cheap but that's not
the case right now and they hope to see
things even out here in las vegas
sooner rather than later it's still wild
yes